uh
thank you all for
making the effort to stay till the last
day i hope that everyone is okay and
well rested after yesterday
uh
yeah so today uh
we have our session from genotype to
phenotype which is the
fundamental question that we discussed
also in the
brainstorm session and our first speaker
is a tony capra from ucsf who will talk
about algorithms for inferring
phenotypes from ancient dna
all right
thank you i'm tony capra from just
across the bay at ucsf and thanks to the
organizers for the invitation to what's
been a really enjoyable workshop so far
and thank you all for showing up
uh you know for the first talk here on
the last day
so
to to motivate what i'm going to talk
about here
this is not advancing
a little bit let me talk about here i'm
going to you know speak to that very
fundamental question that we i think all
have touched on in some way or another
in the work we do and that's how does
genetic variation influence phenotypic
variation
and i think that you know most of us in
our work at least
in some way are thinking about this with
the ultimate goal of understanding how
genetic variation relates to variation
in disease or disease risk or disease
states and better understanding of those
states so hopefully we can we can do
something to better treat it
but when i reflected on the title of
this workshop from from algorithms to
discovery in genome-scale biology i
decided that it might be more
interesting to talk about some some work
that my lab has been doing thinking
about a different opportunity i see
for algorithms to really enable
fundamental discovery
in biology and that's in using them to
infer
traits that are relevant to human
evolution in particular ancient traits
and this has really great performative
transformative potential i believe
because
ancient phenotypes are really hard to
obtain you know where we're sort of
working from material that's coming from
very harsh environments like uh this
denisova cave in in siberia that's been
really a font of influential uh material
in terms of our understanding of of of
uh archaea commonands or our close
relatives
but you know what you get out is really
decayed
limited material and while i've been
incredibly impressed by what the
physical anthropologists can infer from
you know a tiny bone fragment or a tooth
about the individual that it came from
those data you know they can't can't
tell us about a lot of the traits we
really really care about
and
i think there's great potential here
because i'm sure as most of you know
um
there's been a real revolution in the
ability to
extract and sequence dna from ancient
material like these these bones and
fossils and so here's a map just showing
locations from around the globe where uh
ancient human dna has has been found and
sequenced and the end down there is
three thousand but really now it's more
like ten thousand different individuals
that have at least some genetic
information tens of ancient individuals
that have at least some genetic
information
these these data over the last 10 years
have been really
transformative and revolutionary in our
understanding
of the recent history of our species
so in particular they've revealed that
recent human history was was much more
dynamic
than previously appreciated that
migration replacement and admixture
between populations were not exceptions
they were really the norm they were
incredibly common going on
all the time and and throughout uh
throughout our history and so as a
result modern populations we appreciate
are are very much combinations of
different ancestral populations that are
themselves the combinations of different
ancestral populations to them and these
populations moved around quite a bit
and
you know the available ancient dna has
really enabled these kinds of
discoveries because you can infer these
ancestral relationships pretty easily
just from a sort of limited number of of
alleles and so the methods that you need
to sort of infer for those kind of
relationships that are relevant to these
questions are are are already pretty
much there
however
i i believe that the
available ancient dna has been way less
useful and it's been less revolutionary
in telling us answers to this question
what were these ancient individuals like
what were their traits how are they
similar to and how are they different
from
those of modern human populations
and this question i think is
particularly important
when it comes to thinking about very
ancient dna which you know sort of
arbitrarily i'll say is is dna from
individuals that lived more than 40 000
years ago and there are now tens of such
samples of humans and our our closest
relatives that are available including
uh a few
high coverage genome sequences
and
this this i think is is most relevant in
terms of thinking about their phenotypes
one because we know very very little
about them
and two because they serve as a really
useful close out group for comparisons
to modern human populations here so
groups like the neanderthals and
denisovans are our closest extinct
relatives it would be wonderful to be
able to know a lot more about their
phenotypes and how they interacted with
their environments
and so
these these individuals uh branched off
from the lineage that became modern
humans roughly 700 000 years ago
and lived across a broad range in in
eurasia for hundreds of thousands of
years before before modern humans ever
even got into those environments
and and as i said we now have uh four
high quality
uh genome sequences from from these
ancient individuals from roughly 50 000
to about 120 000 years ago
and so to sort of restate this question
you know we're really interested in how
do modern humans and their diversity
relate to neanderthals and denisovans
these closely related groups and i
should say that the denisovans you know
are particularly
important when it comes to this this
idea of using genetic information for
phenotypes because they were not even
known to exist before genetic
information was able to be extracted
from the fossils the the the the bone
that that sort of defined the denisovans
seemed like probably neanderthal but
until the dna came out
and so you know that just that reveals
how very little we know about what you
know what they were like
so
that's the big question
um so if we're going to think about that
i think the natural thing to do is to go
back to this context where so many of us
are doing work and thinking is that how
do we predict phenotypes from genetic
information in modern populations
and so i think many of you are probably
familiar with and you know perhaps this
is the first place your head went the
concept of a polygenic risk score or a
prs
and the basic idea of this is you go out
and you find a population you're
interested in you genotype or sequence
them so you identify genetic variants
across the population
then you do a genome-wide association or
study or you look at an available
genome-wide association study that sort
of estimated the effects of dosage of
those alleles
on the the trait of interest or
variation in the trait of interest
and then what's usually done is a sort
of a simple linear model where the
presence of the variance is weighted by
the effects from from the gwas
and then the evaluation of that
predicted risk or predicted trait value
is is associated with the or you can be
compared with with the actual values and
then that can be applied to new
individuals that you do not have
the the sort of phenotype information
for or you want to predict future
phenotypes for okay
so i think an idea probably familiar to
most of them
right unfortunately for this application
i think
prs will not work for us um you know
there are a couple couple reasons i say
that so first the prs overall accuracy
is is not great for a lot of traits so
here's just one example from a paper
from a couple of years ago that looked
at a range of blood related
traits
and so on the x-axis our traits on the
y-axis is the r-squared of the
prediction to the observed trait in the
uk biobank european
population
and so
you can see that these are these are
decent there's definitely a signal there
but it's not great if you really care
about the prediction for one individual
and so as a result a lot of the the
excitement about prs these days is sort
of looking at individuals at the
extremes and sort of contrasting them
and thinking about interventions that
might work on them
great for for clinical applications but
not necessarily what we're trying to do
here you may also see that there are two
different uh colors here the red
represents um
applying a prs developed from a g was in
european populations the blue represents
applying a prs developed in the biobank
of japan so a population of the east
asian ancestry different from the uk
biobank population here you can see
these values are lower right
so
and and this unfortunately is a general
pattern it's seen um across a lot of
polygenic risk scores where you have
decreases in prediction accuracy as you
move further away in terms of ancestry
from the population in which it was
trained
okay and i think that that makes sense
when we think about the genetic
architecture
of of these complex traits and the
demographic history of human populations
you often end up with situations where
the the other population you might be
applying it to will have variants that
were just missing from the the the the
population that the geowas has performed
in and and the varying effects for those
that are shared may actually still be
different
and so there's a lot of work going on in
human genetics trying to improve the the
portability or generalizability of these
models but they i think are really not
there for the idea that i'm proposing
here of trying to apply it to it even
further diverged population of ancient
individuals
however all hope i believe is not lost
um there have also been some you know
great advances over the last five to ten
years
in machine learning methods for
predicting molecular phenotypes from dna
sequence so rather than trying to go all
the way from genotype to organism level
phenotype
they predict things like transcript
levels or methylation levels or histone
modifications or as we talked about
things like alpha fold that predict
protein structure from from from
sequence
and there are a whole range of such
methods that are that are out there and
so my my thought is perhaps we can use
these sorts of methods to sort of get a
more low-level molecular foothold on
relevant phenotypes that can then be
used to move up to these higher level
phenotypes that ultimately i think many
of us are interested in
and so i'm going to give you one example
of of trying to do that today
and we'll focus on
um genome folding
and so i think if you were here a couple
days ago that this will be very familiar
to you from from jones talk
the dna
our genome is is crammed into our
nucleus
and the 3d structure of it the the
relationships of where different parts
of the genome are to others is actually
very relevant in influencing how genes
are regulated and what parts of the
genome may regulate other parts of the
genome so for example if you imagine
this linear sequence here represents the
dna
and the colors are just indicating so we
can sort of indicate linear positions
along it
there might be a region that's folded
like this
um there have been a bunch of assays
that have been developed over the last
10 years to try to quantify this
crumpling confirmation um hi-c perhaps
this is one you're most familiar with
what ultimately comes out is is a
triangle that looks like this that
relates the contact frequencies of
different pairs of
windows along the linear genome
so for example in our little schematic
here the orange and blue bits are
close together and thus much more likely
to be nearby and in contact and so we
would have a
red value here meaning
that these are close in 3d space or much
more likely to be in contact
whereas the red and purple bits are
quite far away in in both linear and 3d
space so they get this blue value and we
can kind of fill in the whole matrix
and what happens is you often see
patterns that look like this where
there's contact domains or topologically
associating domains
that represent these kinds of loops
where dna within them is much more
likely to be interacting with each other
and regulating each other than even
components that are closer by in linear
space
if they are outside of that tab okay so
this is you're going to see some a bunch
of these so
that's that's how you interpret them
and
in particular my colleague at ucsf uh
katie pollard uh published a a deep
learning model
called akita
for trying to predict from
dna sequence alone so basically a one
megabase chunk of the genome
um to predict the high c map so one of
those maps and this is just the same map
but you know symmetric
um
like i was showing before
and um so what what they do is basically
you know now a fairly standard sort of
deep learning uh
approach
to
predict that 2kb resolution these
contact maps and then we can do that
across the genome and they find that
these are actually
predictions are actually quite accurate
especially when it comes to the overall
structure
of of these regions in terms of their 3d
folding
okay
so the idea is can we now use methods
like this
to begin to think about this question
so
i chose genome folding not randomly
but because
we believe that you know thanks to work
of some people in this room even that uh
recent human evolution has mainly been
driven by changes in gene regulation
right so
there are many ways that that variants
could affect this complex process of
gene regulation and so today we're going
to focus on
um oops today we're going to focus on
the 3d structure
so basically trying to understand how
the structure of the genome might relate
to its expression and ultimate
expression in phenotypes and you know of
course i don't want to belabor this
point but we won't ever be able to do
high c
on
neanderthal material all we get is
basically you know very very small dna
fragments
we actually do have some ideas about how
we might be able to try to reconstruct
some contacts based on the the
fragmentation patterns but that's for
another day
so the idea is instead can algorithms
help us here can can they help us infer
what that 3d folding pattern might look
like from a human sequence and a
neanderthal sequence and then compare
them
okay
all right so just
the the setup is basically we have an
input sequence from an ancient
individual
we put it through this model akita that
was trained to predict 3d structures and
we get outputs that look like this
and we're going to ask a range of
questions with with this approach so
first we'll just try to quantify
what did the neanderthal 3d organization
look like as i said before there are a
handful of whole genome sequences of
high coverage from three neanderthals
and one denisovan from
these locations here here and here it
covers through a wide range of geography
and time
and we'll also apply these methods to a
set of diverse modern human genomes from
the thousand genomes projects so we get
a quantification of kind of the
diversity that's present in modern
populations as well
we'll look at sliding one megabase
windows along the genome
and then compare the resulting contact
maps from the neanderthal and the human
contexts and we expect that most regions
of the genome will look like this little
schematic where they are very similar we
do not expect this to have evolved you
know substantially but we also hope that
we may find some regions that look like
this where there is divergence
and i'll say that you know the the the
the data i'll be showing you today will
mainly be quantifying this divergence is
basically one minus a spearman
correlation over the contact map
we've also done all of this looking at
mean squared differences
as well and the patterns are similar
we also have a paper we're trying to
sort of develop and benchmark other more
biologically motivated comparison
methods but i've not applied them here
okay
so the question is
what do these maps look like and how
different are they and so just to get
your intuition going i'm going to show a
few examples
so here is a comparison for a given
region on chromosome 16 of one megabase
of the human contact map the neanderthal
contact map and then down here to help
facilitate the comparisons i know it can
be kind of hard especially on different
screens to detect these differences i'm
showing you essentially the delta in
contact frequency with green meaning
more contacts in modern humans purple
meaning
more contacts in the neanderthal and so
here is a fairly representative region
very little difference
at the other extreme here's a region
that's at the 99.9 percentile of
divergence according to to this our
metric
and you can see especially down here
there's this whole stripe of increased
human um uh
contact and then some focal bits here of
um increased neanderthal contacts so
there's quite quite a bit of difference
in the structure here that we think
could be relevant and then we see a full
spectrum of of differences between
between those extremes
oh of course
the sequence determinants are
similar
yeah
thank you for asking that so as we saw
for the project risk scores they did not
generalize
i'm proposing
that these kinds of molecular predictors
are much more likely to generalize
across
populations and even species because
i don't think that the basic biology
of how
genome folding
is determined by the the
sequence has dramatically changed
now we can't test that directly on
neanderthals but we can test that
by looking at chimp sequences
and i do have the slide showing
so
here's an example comparing
a human
uh observed map and a chimpanzee
actually actually two fans of data um on
the top
where we see a very big difference
between the human
contact patterns and the chimp contact
patterns for the corresponding region of
the genome
and akita captures this
at least qualitatively very well
we see a decrease in performance across
the genome in terms of the accuracy of
if we apply the human model to the chimp
sequence you know in a context where we
have actually a experimental chimp ic
map
it's it's maybe 10 to 20 percent less
accurate
than in the corresponding human region
so absolutely there is a decrease but
it's it's not i think as bad as in the
the prs case
it also depends a bit on cell type and
so that's another issue that i haven't
directly talked about here is that these
models are based on six different cell
types in a combined
context we also have cell type specific
models
and in general
the the sort of high level architecture
of these one megabase regions is pretty
conserved across the cell types so we
haven't delved super deep into that but
we have
new methods we're developing that are
trying to emphasize self type specific
differences that we we are applying so
it's absolutely um
true that we don't think we have great
cell type specific specificity of these
models in the chimp comparison we've
compared
human models trained on different cell
types predicting the one chimp cell type
we have data for and they're pretty
similar in how they generalize
does that does that help
okay yeah
so when when you look at platinum
expression
differences between species vessels
between the organs that you know that
you have much more of the specific
species then you can cell type would
that be the similar situation with the
compact map because they are more
similar across the species if you use
the same cell type and more differences
within the same organization
yeah so it hasn't been anywhere near as
well
comprehensively characterized as gene
expression across tissues and species is
um the divergence
in both dimensions i think is way lower
for the 3d contact maps
um
but you you would i think see
that's actually a good question i don't
know the study that's had
data across
tissues from another species with humans
you can do it mouse mouse is human i
guess there's enough data
um so i don't know for sure but i think
it would be a lot more similar though
across the species
he
i just don't have the plot here and so
so that that's basically that like 10 to
20 reduction was coming from if you
train on
human and apply across the whole chip
genome
the accuracy you know decreases from
like point two to
point or like i guess it depends on
whether you do experiment or it means
whatever but yeah it's about 15 to 20
percent of the aerometric across the
gene i'm going to do that
yeah yeah
so try to understand the biological
basis behind the changes and things that
you need to account only for changes in
part
organization which means you need to
look only for mutations that affect the
cities they have right inside otherwise
whatever outside of those regions
unlikely to change
yeah
so so that that's a a very good point
that a lot of the signal that the deep
learning method it's finding is coming
from ctcf but it is by no means only
from ctcf variation
so and this is this is katy's work they
showed that they get a significant
improvement by looking at the full
sequence compared to like if you just
quantified how many you know disrupt how
many disruptions you've seen this yeah
there so there is more on top of ctcf
but i'll show you the moment often a lot
of the drivers think behind these
differences are
characteristic changes in c2cf machines
okay
um
so let me get back here
all right so here is now the the
distribution of this this 3d divergent
score in this case it's like a one minus
spirited across
the window and you see that most of the
genome
is is very very very similar and there
are a few out here that we're
potentially more interested
i think i'll skip this for time but
basically we showed that
indeed there seems to be constraint on
maintaining 3d genome contact so if you
simulate
regions of the genome with similar
divergence similar mutation patterns you
would expect more difference than we
actually observe between humans and
neanderthals
so the the first question we have really
though are are there really neanderthal
specific 3d contact patterns that were
developed that were identifying
and so the um the way we
we searched for this was to look for
cases where
all pairwise comparisons between a set
of 20 representative african individuals
um
were were very similar to one another
and small
and then the difference between the
comparison of the archaic individual to
all pairs of african individuals were
all larger than any pair of african
individuals
so we want to find situations where they
are much
uh the neanderthal to uh each modern
human individual we have is much more
different than any pair of modern humans
okay and so that's in contrast to what
most of the genome looks like which is
more like this where the the pairwise
distributions
of uh divergence are very overlapping i
think there hasn't been much difference
and so you know we can sort of do some
simulation to try to get a sense of the
false discovery rate and put different
thresholds on this but at a low uh false
discovery rate we find about
150-ish regions you know the exact
number of courses contingent on whatever
threshold you want to use
that that we have that we say have
significant human archaic 3d divergence
and here's sort of where they're
distributed across the genome and then
here's how they are shared across the
archaic individuals and so as you'd
expect from sequence patterns and
evolutionary patterns the neanderthals
are much more likely to share
divergent regions with one another than
with the denisovan who split off from
their lineage not too long after they
all split from the lineage became us
and so this gives us a set of regions to
start to start thinking about um
and so you know to answer this sort of
first question yes we can use this model
we can apply it to
a
an archaic sequence and get
predictions that essentially make sense
given what we we know and expect
so can these differences provide me
clues to human neanderthal phenotypic
divergence
just to give you one example
here's a particular contact map actually
in the interest of time i'm going to i
think go through this a little bit
quickly so we can do examples we can
sort of do in silico mutagenesis using
these models evaluating different
variants along the genome and find
candidates that seem to be main drivers
of the change and as as anticipated in
many cases these are
very interpretable given what we know
about the biology of how these loops are
maintained and so for example here's a
neanderthal change that disrupts a ctcf
motif
leading to increased 3d contact at the
icos promoter this is a cell surface
receptor that's really important in cell
cell signaling and immune response
and so this this sort of gives us a sort
of way we could dig in and generate some
specific hypotheses at this locus about
differences between means neanderthals
but we also of course can do you know
the sort of things we
we all have to do when we want to
generate larger hypotheses and let's ask
are there any traits
with genes enriched in the regions of 3d
diversions so imagine taking these
regions
we tested for enrichment of annotations
both from rare disease from the human
phenotype ontology and common disease
from essentially the gwas catalog
for genes that were in the tads that are
divergent between humans and
neanderthals and and for me this was a
really you know i usually do these kinds
of analyses and find some stuff that i
can't interpret at all this was really
striking to me what we ended up finding
so here is in the rare disease
annotations
um along the x-axis is basically just
divided by disease domains
and um this this top dashed line is at a
fdr of 0.05 the bottom one is fdr 0.1
we find some some interesting uh traits
such as lower anterior hairline and
underdeveloped superorbital ridges and
now you know this is one of the most
stereotyped differences between modern
humans and neanderthals the you know the
classic
strong
brow ridge so it's it's it was amazing
to me to see something like this
and this is essentially saying that
genes that are in these divergent
3d regions
are enriched for
being involved in the specification of a
number of these uh hair and lymph
skeletal traits okay
and so i think those genes now sort of
become very very interesting in terms of
how they are regulated and how that
might relate to some of these these
known differences we also see you know
this is the set of uh sort of visual and
optic phenotypes which also actually
correlates somewhat nicely with with
things that are already known in terms
of neanderthals having larger orbits and
and sort of differences in the visual
uh
processing machinery at least estimated
to have that based on the structure of
their their brain cases
um on the you know the common disease
side i think we could spend you know
hours or even days trying to interpret
all of these but again there are quite a
few both um i think reassuring
observations here and then also some
some provocative ones that we're
interested in trying to follow up in
more detail specifically about those
genes all right so
of course all this is based on
three regions
oh no this is well we've done these for
different subsets
of these plots i'm sorry of these um
uh uh divergent regions this one i
believe is over
all of them
yes this is overall 167.
and the way we do the enrichment is by
looking at genes that fall in the
topologically associating domains so
it's not just that number of genes it's
uh it's a higher number just a few
hundred solds
three to five genes
something like something like that yeah
and we do simulations to try to estimate
what these fdrs really are
um based on the fact that you know
different genes have different
probabilities of being put into a tab
based on the size of the tads so we sort
of try to account for those biases along
the genome in terms of gene size and pad
size
this is the divergence
and so it's basically what if you look
at other regions that have conserved
tasks
and the genes involved in them but match
to properties of the you know the size
and gene density of the tasks that have
changed at least as well as we can
through the permutations
yeah
and so
i don't think we're getting a lot of
cell type specificity i think we're
getting
what are sort of like global probably
across the most cell type changes
in the past you don't really care where
you know the differences are relative to
the gene as long as they're within that
tag
yeah we've done it a couple ways we've
tried using just sort of nearest gene
type strategies and most of this is the
same but um
uh but yeah we in this analysis we're
basically looking just at genes
so sorry since
since the two plots are different so i
think that you're only showing us the
annotation specific for vertices and for
common disease right
but then what happens if you just show
the global map i mean how many things
are not annotated there have nothing to
do with with diseases or with traits
that we cannot relate to differences
between
yeah
and us there are if i understood
correctly you know we have very
different power for different types of
traits based on what we know about
their relationship to disease in modern
human populations
and you know that's in part why we've
kept these separated they are just like
different sets of mappings from genes to
phenotypes
um
you know i
i don't have a great handle on
so i guess the question is do you do you
find many things
terms that are engaged but we cannot
really explain on the board that
apparently there's no difference between
uh yeah i mean like if we look if we
look at it
many of these are kind of on that
spectrum
because a lot of these differences
really are
anecdotal i mean we are playing that
game of okay what has been proposed
based on the limited fossil
information or um compare other
comparisons of the the genomes
and
you know
qualitatively many of these overlap well
with those as i was pointing out others
like you know i don't know what to say
about cannabis use
for example in terms of how to interpret
if anyone has ideas about
solving this problem i would love to
talk about it because
it i don't know how to sort of really
get beyond the anecdote
um from these other than digging into
the specific genes and showing sort of
how they were divergently regulated
showing there was evolution you know
signatures of selection on those
variants
that at least
bolsters the case that's relevant but
it's still hard to necessarily say it
was that
[Music]
i swear that i did not plant him in the
uh in the audience because that's
exactly what we did next
um so i think many of you likely know
that uh modern humans and these archaea
comedians overlapped in space at times
space and time at various uh
uh sort of times and locations in our
recent history
somewhere around 40 000 years ago
there was interbreeding
and you know as i said before this is
sort of a common feature of human
evolutionary history people
interbred
when they could and so so there's lots
of instances of this this is inferred
from sort of sequence information but as
a result of this you know somewhere
around 40 or 50 percent of the
neanderthal genome
remains
in a sense in
modern human genomes due to those
admixture events
and so the question is essentially what
i'm asking here
did humans inherit any 3d organization
from neanderthals i think that's the
question
and so what we did is we took
these
167
divergent 3d structures that we
identified in the neanderthals and now
remember i only used african ancestry
individuals in defining these because
african ancestry individuals have very
low levels of neanderthal
ancestry just based on the fact that
neandertals were outside of europe and
i'm sorry outside of africa
and most of the interbreeding happened
out there there was a little bit of
backflow but
the the levels in african individuals is
quite small
so
our hope is that there might be
signatures well
i don't know our hope is but our idea is
can we detect signatures of any of these
neanderthal or archaic 3d
contact patterns in modern eurasian
populations
and so just as an example of of what i'm
talking about so here's a region
one of our divergent regions where
there's an african contact pattern that
is different
from
the neanderthal contact pattern so in in
the africans you have this sort of one
large domain neanderthals you have these
two smaller domains and there's sort of
a ctcf motif here
if this you know so so we then looked in
the eurasian populations at a range of
individuals most people looked like this
they had the african
quote unquote uh contact pattern but
there were several individuals
that had
predicted introduction at this location
and that resulted in the neanderthal
contact pattern
and so yeah this was really exciting um
and it was not um
you know i have another example here
showing that we can kind of show that
that intragressed allele is associated
with gene expression associated with
phenotypes in modern human populations
in this case it's a it's a growth factor
binding protein and it's associated with
height and and some other bmi related
traits so again something potentially
evolutionarily relevant and relevant to
some known differences between humans
and neanderthals but also that may have
been brought back to modern populations
through integration
yeah we do have so and and i should say
that these examples
are
based on
doing an in-silico
neogenesis where we put in each variant
in turn
of the neanderthal variants into the
human background
and scan those and find those that have
the highest effect
but often you know there are additional
effects outside of it
in terms of you know it's not
necessarily just the ctcf motif for sure
but we do have diversion examples where
there is no obvious ctcf motif
disruption but those are by far the
minority
so i think you would get a lot of these
if you just sort of looked at ctcf
variants between humans and neanderthals
but you certainly wouldn't get all of
them
yeah so those are
four individual examples when you look
at the populations and the number of
individual genomes that you have to pan
out actually yeah yeah so exactly so
the amount of introduction that you have
in a one megabase window is really
strongly correlated with
how similar to the neanderthal contact
pattern you look
i have a
let me see if it's easy to get
a qualification of that
let's see somewhere
i'll i'll come back to that thank you
very much i know i'm already a little
over yeah okay okay
okay sorry um
so basically 24 of these archaic
uh divergent regions we were able to
find at least one modern human and as i
said the amount of neandertal ancestry
that an individual has in a region
correlates with the similarity of their
contact map to a neanderthal and so that
that is very significant
um so in in summary i i've shown you how
an example of how we can try to use
sequence-based machine learning methods
for predicting molecular phenotypes to
under hopefully understand better
the molecular traits of
uh long extinct or long gone individuals
um and this is really just one example i
think there's great potential to be
doing this with a lot of other traits so
we have
um a pre-print out on this this example
which i really encourage you to check
out and send me any comments i'd love to
hear it we're doing sort of experimental
validation now of some of the introduced
human variants um
that i think will really sort of seal
the deal um we have a paper from a
couple years ago where we did this on
predicting transcript levels
and and similarly found some some you
know
uh exciting differences
and that that that does get that's a lot
easier to get cell type specific given
our better models for predicting cell
type specificity of gene expression
um and then we've got a review that we
just uh published a couple months ago
summarizing all of the approaches in
this in this field and pointing out that
you know if you think this is a really
promising way to go so again uh thanks
i'm sorry i went a little bit over but i
really appreciate all the comments and
would love to talk more
[Applause]
one more question which i think
is kind of important when you go back to
the traits
um
there were some that we can easily see
that you know there might have been
selection for intelligence
and this is something that that you know
had
homo sapiens
um but there were others that are more
related to diseases and i was wondering
if you sometimes find
disease traits in proximity or genes for
interest rates in proximity for
beneficial traits
yeah and this could explain how how
beneficial traits dominated selection
and we are more susceptible to some
diseases that the ancient populations
might not have had yeah yeah i think we
see this most strongly in the immune
system
where an allele that may be detrimental
in a modern
environment
might have actually been quite
beneficial so even maybe the same
same effect can have different these are
the same variants and different
impressions of the environment
then of course also i think there's
there is plyo trophy in these loci and
especially when you think about the 3d
genome organization there are multiple
genes that's why that was really
important that you have one scene that
promotes intelligence another one that
finished with ibd and you know the
intelligence being selected for in the
ipd kind of
yeah i think that's a good that's a good
question we haven't tried to use
the the tag information to look for
potentially like you know antagonistic
interactions right like that i think you
could yeah
i'm good sorry
thank you very much